[Music] If
you do, there's fishinfani on
the side of the road What kind of secrets are hidden in each side dish
?
In the rain of sweet potatoes, I
don't crush this while
soaking it in orange juice. Only the mouthpieces that are originally used for yellow coloring are formed with orange juice
.
Mixed with sugar and salt in a mixer and grilled
Mogayaki If you mix the red and white namase salad vegetables with sugar, salt and vinegar, the namasu will be
soaked in the sweet vinegar by sprinkling salt and squeezing it to prevent water damage.
The reason for the uncured ham is that the radish and carrot on the vegetable stick is wrapped in uncured ham, and the honey and tool
mustard are also used as glue on the inside.
This osechi is a course meal. No matter where you start or in what order you eat it, it will go well
with you.
In the middle of the day, there's more freedom in pump riders. It
only takes a few minutes to create such a delicate menu without a cap.
Mr.
Goroshi is a side dish made at a convenience store, so it's a white
that can be made without using the 3-year-old's over-the-
counter [music]
ni
yeah yeah yeah until autumn [music] ime don't eat water
[music]